thank you welcome to the nightmare
session how many of you had perfect data
when you began your analysis that had no
missing values that had no duplicates
all right that's what I thought so
that's gonna be the topic of our
presentation we're going to talk about
the dirty data and we're also going to
demonstrate some cleanup methodologies
using the data set public data set that
is that that's using the Fitbit data
from some group of people so a little
bit about us Tonya is the vice president
of model governance and review at
JPMorgan myself is the Faculty of
analytics at Harrisburg University and
I'm also the data science advisor at
metadata i/o which is the marketing
based marketing account based marketing
start-up so excel first came in as Lotus
1-2-3 back in the 70s
IBM well I believe IBM was the first one
who you know acquired later acquired the
tool later on acquired the company later
on however still up to this day
according to Gartner Excel is the most
used most you know most popular bi tool
in the world so if you look at the Magic
Quadrant Microsoft is actually being at
the very lead of all other tools so the
reality is that no matter how
sophisticated is your bi tool people
will still convert it to excel and work
in Excel and then upload it back to your
sophisticated tool for which you're
paying a lot of a lot of money so bottom
line is that Excel is the most widely
used analytical tool in the world so if
we're talking about data
dirty data significant quantities are
stored and passed around in in the
spreadsheet because again
the adoption rate is very high the
analysis are also frequently performed
without leaving Excel and this can lead
to very aggravating data quality issues
so when the data happens to be not as
clean as you hoped serious errors can
occur in and you have to deal with the
you have to deal with these errors
through the work cycle another
statistics from the public research
company IDG estimates that about 60 60
percent of the data science workflow is
taking occupied by the data cleanup
so eventually majority of the data
science is eventually what they're doing
they're doing data engineering
essentially some of the common types of
dirty data are missing data duplicates
outliers multiple comma separated or not
values crunch into the same cell and
column headers as values or variable
names not variable names so there are a
couple of ways of handling dirty data
one would be the data database level
manual cleanup which is non scalable and
unofficial the other one is the
application level the recommended way
basically you're trying to hack of the
problems at their inception had the
Wickham is the British statistician who
developed in 2014 published developed
and published the article on the cut
with the concepts of Tidy data so the
main concepts are the observations
should be as rows variables should be as
columns and you have to have one
observational unit per per table which
is actually relates very closely to the
normalization concept
so to demonstrate how to you know to
demonstrate some methodologies on of
data cleanup we have a data set a
publicly available Fitbit data set
containing about records on about 33
customers with the minute-by-minute
records on steps ins intensities as well
as daily distances travel and data
quality issues were manually introduced
by us for the purposes of this
demonstration with the objective to
provide a simple example that
illustrates how data quality issues may
affect the results of the analysis as
well as to estimate the more tactical
objective is to estimate the customers
height based on the average stride
length and see what the results belong
at the expected ranges so the tools we
use were obviously Excel Python 3.5 and
Jupiter so initial data that we had
consists of three consisted of three
data sets the minute steps minute
intensities in daily distances the
minute steps is pretty self-explanatory
it lists the steps the observed unit
made per minute the minute intensities
estimates the so the intensity is the
measure that estimates how intense was
the step so in other words if I'm
walking from here to the next chair the
intensity would be zero and then it goes
up with three being very intense maybe
running or jumping daily distances has
the other senses has three three
variables light active distance
moderately active distance and very
active distance which come up to the
total distance walk throughout the day
so the quick and dirty height
calculation I probably should use this
slide
so the first step we've done we merged
this two data sets we've merged minute
intensities with the steps just because
the measures you know the variables are
very similar and we were able to merge
them by the IDs
the reason we did that was we wanted to
have the ability to filter through the
intensity which we eliminated all
observations where intensity was zero
next step we use the daily we merge the
resulting data set with the daily
distances and finally we arrived at our
model which is down down below so the
reason we didn't go into sophisticated
calculations because again the purpose
of this demonstration is the data
cleanup and not the actual calculation
so what we did we essentially we using
the distance divided by number of steps
multiplied by the coefficient the
coefficient is actually something that
was looked up on the web
I believe Fitbit has this calculator
Fitbit has this coefficient posted and
and finally the last line is the
formatting of the formatting of the
output once who ran the model some of
the height calculated by the by the
formula were clear you know were clear
outliers we you know there was a 3/5
three feet tall person there was an 853
person 13 feet and one point and a half
feet so that's clearly erroneous data so
two to elaborate on how we clean it up
I'll pass it to my peer hi everyone so
so what yeah so I'm going to explain how
I cleaned up the data but before I do so
I'm going back again to here so we chose
this little simple model to send this
message to everyone that cleaning data
is super super important your model can
be you know it doesn't have to be as
simple as we chose it could be very
sophisticated very
interesting and very valid model but if
you feed your valid model dirty data
you're not gonna get anything meaningful
in the outcome and the reason we chose
this example is to illustrate that you
can visually see how the observations
are really off you can visually see that
a person cannot be 113 feet high it's
just it just doesn't happen so here you
can see it in most practical instances
what happens is you wouldn't see this
visually like when you look at your
results you won't be able to tell that
you had some problems in your data that
caused this because you wouldn't I mean
everything is generally more nuanced
than this so this is just to send the
message that this is very important and
I've personally I've been working at JP
Morgan for I've been validating models
for almost four years and this aspect
has been overlooked continuously and
this message doesn't get across people
model but people don't look at the data
so was that sad I'm gonna move on and to
cleaning up and see what we can do I
mean first and foremost is what you do
with your data is you actually need to
look at it this is a few simple ways how
you look at it in pandas however of
course going more sophisticated with
data visualizations and other methods is
important here we'll only focus on the
very simple observations so there are a
couple of simple things you can use
there is an info function in pandas and
describe they do different things so
describe gives you the like basic
statistics on the integers and floats
and info gives you information about
your variables what kind of data types
they are how many observations there are
so first thing first let's see what we
can see from this data set and I hope
this yeah there's a pointer No
so they describes first of all you can
see that you saw that the minute steps
and intensities they look very similar
in terms of data right you have ID you
have activity minutes and then you have
your variable U value steps or intensity
here when you look at the scribe they
look different what happened so one
thing you can notice as the ID is a
numerical value it's it's an integer for
four
ten cities but it's not an integer for
the steps and you can see it in the info
as well you have the data type object so
this is something to be we're worried
about there's something wrong is you're
in your data that makes one integer and
another not another thing you can see is
that the most of values are zero so even
75th percentile is zero for both and you
can also see that for the steps the
maximum value is sort of off it says
that a person walked 500 steps per
minute that's too much so you also have
outliers in this data other observations
you can see that there are some null
values in the steps in this inner steps
type table because if you look in the
counts in the in the info slide the the
counts are officers there are not null
values and another track is a number of
customer IDs in the steps and
intensities are different one it should
is 3 another 36 which also kind of asks
you why why is it happening why isn't
matching together so you can see a lot
by just doing this very simple thing and
this is kind of a message always do it
before you proceed so those are just the
observations I just mentioned we have a
different number of records we we have a
lot of zeros we have nulls for sure we
have different number of unique user IDs
some object data types for something
that shouldn't be like well ID doesn't
have to be an integer but you know when
one is integer one is not and the
maximum number of steps per minute is
500 which is also too many one file we
haven't looked yet its daily distances
[Music]
one thing we can see is that the number
of you jika IDs for this one actually
matches the intensities so sorry 3 seems
to be the right number not 36 and we can
also see that the
it's for different types of distances
here which may or may not correspond to
intensities there's a sedentary active
distance and then the light and moderate
and very active we will assume that they
do correspond to the intensity so we
only look at the distances that are more
active so having those observations in
mind let's go and actually clean the
dataset so first thing first look at the
look at the ideas and see what may be
wrong with them so this of minute steps
is where the problem is and if you look
at them you can actually see that there
are some weird things start happening on
the second column where you have some
beard strings with some additional
characters appearing and that's what
causing the problem so we need to clean
this up and another thing you can see is
that the minute intensities has way too
many record and if you try dropping
duplicates you you basically you can see
how tall you actually have dupes whole
duplicate rows in this data frame so if
you start merging that's the first thing
we did in the dirty calculation before
this is the if you start looking
carefully how many records you have when
you start merging two so you can see
that it changes you have three different
numbers you have number of records and
minute steps number of records and
minute intensities and the number of
records and emerges just don't they're
not the same which is not what you
should be expecting like ideally they
should match one by one together so to
clean it up we first convert the IDS to
integers we just clean up all the dirty
characters so this is what the first
function is doing and the second thing
we are doing is we just drop in
duplicates in the in the minute
intensities because they're just there
we know those records are fully
duplicates of each other and once we do
that you can see that the merging works
well there's no problem anymore
so now we have records matching one to
one the next problem is slightly more
complicated so once you figure out the
duplicates and things start matching
together
nouns and outliers are the harder
problem because you actually have to
conceptually understand what they mean
in in this particular instance we kind
of won't go a mile to do that but in
general you need to understand why your
knots are occurring in our case it's we
introduce them but in your case it's
probably something else and why outliers
what do you mean by outlier why do you
think this is outlier and something else
is not so it's usually a very tricky
question but here here we just given
again one simple example so missing
values usually missing values are
treated using imputations there are
multiple kinds there are simple single
imputations or multiple imputations
which basically ask you you you impute
it multiple times do your analysis and
then kind of take an average or look at
the distribution of your possible
outcomes but generally speaking the idea
is you're trying to predict what your
you missed so you can do the same as
outliers you can either just exclude
them or you can kind of impute them as
well because if you think your outlier
occurred because I don't know the device
that has been collecting data is broken
or something happened that there's no
something technical then theoretically
you may want to replace it with an
imputed value so the tip most typical
single imputation are mean substitution
you can substitute the just put mean
value instead of a missing record this
is a valid method if you only have very
few of them and you don't think it's
going to blow you know affect your
results significantly but sometimes the
mean can do all kind of a bad job for
you for example if you are trying to
actually estimate the average number of
Records you are losing your noise in a
sense by replacing things by the mean
another one set is interpolation which
is usually meaningful if you have time
series data which what we do in this
case we have a per minute information so
we can use interpolation to impute the
values there
also some people just delete the data
it's sometimes a valid method when you
delete the records in our case it's not
going to work because we have we have to
match our information with daily
distances and the daily distances are
daily distance so if you throw some of
the minutes from the intensity source
steps then they're not going to match
conceptually to the daily distance so we
can't throw away records but there
aren't situations in which this is a
valid message to proceed as long as you
don't throw away too much data it may be
okay another way of imputation is to
replace with a random value so the one
is hot that is you take kind of values
that you have in your data set and just
replace with the random one of the
existing values the callback is a
similar method using a data set that is
different from yours and more
sophisticated management you can use a
regression to impute the values but the
regression again you need to be very
careful about it because you are again
replacing so to speak with an average
average per category in some sense in
the regression so you are losing some of
the noise in the regression so just a
quick note that the multiple imputation
in out of those messes the hot back or a
cold that would be kind of a suitable
for multiple regression where you can
try different values you can randomly
select one and then randomly select
another in another and see how how it
works it's often a recommended method
because you often don't have enough data
or you have you know you need to impute
too many values or things like that so
in salmon in some instances it actually
gives you kind of a better estimate in
the end so so there are advantages is
relatively flexible it's easy to
implement and it gives you sort of a
better view the disadvantages are
sometimes it's not giving you any
additional benefit so in our example it
turns out that with the methods we tried
it doesn't give you an additional
benefit so it is more computationally
intensive but in this case it
give you anything but you definitely
should try it and see if if that works
in your case so back to example so this
is just a plot of the step distribution
spur intensity what you can observe is
for intensity one the distribution kind
of looks that goes down sort of
exponentially I don't know but it
there's a clear kind of stepping down
and then the intensity two and three
look more like normals in so that the
the the scales account and then those
histograms of the of the number of steps
so just visually we have most of the
intensities are one I mean aside from
zero in in this distribution and so
that's why we kind of when we did the
model we chose this sort of average
stride lengths between running and
walking so because we don't have too
many observations in the intensity two
two and three two kind of models and
separately
so now let's impute so this one simply
makes a single imputation using the mean
we compute mean per customer not mean
per you know per the hopper the whole
time because we would expect that the
mean number of steps would depend on the
person who's very in fitbit some but
some people run more some people less so
we'll compute that per customer and then
we just simply replace all the nulls and
all the all the all the rows where you
have 500 as a outlier
another one is interpolation we simply
interpolate here with with the previous
value so basically if you walked I don't
know 30 steps in a given minute and then
there have a missing value in the next
minute right sorry until you find a
non-missing value so it's like there are
many different types of interpolation
you can also use the average between the
two or so you can specify in the
interpolate and here you can specify
what kind of interpolation you're
looking for and another one we used was
the hot deck is the random choice so we
basically took the distribution of
existing values for the steps and
plugged it in and for that we we use the
transform method for the pandas which
allows you to sort of transform your
data series into something else and here
we just we kept the same value if we
existed and if not then we just do
randomly from the same customer so now
it's just rewriting our model so to
speak into a function so once again we
already merge the two files so now we
only need to filter out the for
intensity bigger than zero some things
up
take the distances which are not sitting
down but actually from some activity of
the customers sum things up and apply
exactly the same model as before and
format the height so that we can
actually better visualize and understand
it
and once we apply it to you know every
single every single of those imputation
values this is the result the result we
only filtered out the situations where
the dirty calculation was different from
the original calculation I took out all
the other customers so we can see well
one thing to notice is in our old graph
back here we only noticed four problems
right four values really stood out in
this graph we actually see five so there
was one that we missed because this one
was six point four which is sort of you
know acceptable height you can't say
it's it's off but this one also had a
problem we couldn't see it visually by
looking at the values but it was there
yeah oh this was other depending on
imputation so height mean height
interpolate and height distribution
where the three imputations that we used
height mean as the imputation will be
used with the mean value interpret as
the interpolate value and the
distribution is the one
did the hot back by selecting the random
choice yes well I mean it's it's a
difficult decision every time percentage
usually works but you it's good to look
at the distribution of your values and
see what they mean is actually a
meaningful parameter so what what
happens in real life here's just one
example you can try all those sort of
things and kind of see how it works but
in production you have to decide if you
actually impute in data in production
during the process you have to decide
which one you use so you need to study
it and see what a mean is appropriate it
depends on what kind of distribute how
distribution looks like whether this is
gonna affect your downstream results if
you start modeling with this data so
it's a tricky question a lot of people
use the mean but it's not necessarily
the best choice a lot of people also use
interpolate but you can see in this
example that it's not really performing
as well as some other methods like for
example the one-point-five problem it
didn't fix it the interpolation so
there's something I mean it's not
necessarily a bad mess at all together
but you need to be careful when decided
which one to use and in this again in
this example the distribution worked out
the best part of the reason is that
because wind when wind when I introduce
those problems in the data set I did
them uniformly at random I randomly
replaced values with mouths and I
randomly added the outliers that's why
when you use a distribution to replace
them you actually kind of get things
back not perfectly but good enough and
other messes are not as good because
they are doing something different but
so so the imputation that you choose
really really depends on the cause of
why you have in the null values or why
you're having the outliers so the asking
goes wise when your data is very very
important and it really various case the
case but this is something that I think
when you do any analysis is something
that
should ask this is before modeling but
it's it's so crucial to the results that
your model can possibly obtain so well
senders bad dataset and we'll figure it
out
I hope and with that we will take
questions my question is when you say
outliers are you referring to a
suspicious data point or my I am a
little confused because when I trained
in the statistics
it was my missions to determine if his
an unusual data points was an outliers
or actually it was an unusual
observation but is still a valid
observation so a made a data could have
these kind of data points that it's wave
you know are now within the group when
I'm sad but I'm not necessarily outliers
so I needed to run the test to find out
if he died in what indeed was in our
liars and if it was in our liars I can
safely remove it and it would not affect
my models but if it was in our Liars the
it was not it it was not then I have to
leave it in there
so in fact an outlier has to be
determined you cannot define it a priori
and I wonder if when you mention
outliers you you are thinking the same
way or I'm confused
so no yeah I fully agree with you it
really depends in our case I just
specifically made it 500 steps for
minute which is practically humanly
impossible to achieve so that is clearly
there's something wrong with the data
and not with its it doesn't sound like a
valid value but if the value was say 200
then you say yeah if you run you may get
200 steps per minute there's nothing
wrong with it so you you you would start
saying oh is it a real outlier or it's
just because somebody is really fast and
they just step a lot so so yes there's
absolutely this question is very
important and another another question
is if you are planning to apply a model
after that it's important how your model
is gonna treat this value if the model
is capable of kind of working around it
so to speak or you know treating them
you know in a right way you can keep
them but in some instances models are
not very sensitive to outliers then you
might have to think about it harder like
regression is relatively sensitive and
so on yeah overall population
distribution for for number of steps yep
yeah so we only had 33 records so the
distribution was as we showed those are
this is only 33 customers so this is I
mean you can plot it as a distribution
but that's that's all we have and for
the ones that we corrected we corrected
those four squares and one of this I
believe this record as well that was
actually off but you couldn't see it and
in this table and once again in this
particular instance we actually
introduced them per customer that's why
they're so clearly per customer
but in in regular life you would
probably I will probably affect all the
records to some extent
not-so-nice thing she goes again
[Applause]